the soldier of the future won't just be
battle trained and ready to kill they'll
be genetically engineered to withstand a
biological attack the Pentagon has a
plan for editing the DNA and creating
super soldiers why's Defense Advanced
Research Projects Agency doing this to
protect a soldier on the battlefield
from chemical weapons and biological
weapons by controlling their genome
having the genome produced proteins that
would automatically protect the soldier
from the inside out so far this sounds a
little bit closer to science fiction
perhaps a bit more fantasy than fact he
will be the first
earlier this year a Chinese scientist
announced that two girls were born with
edited genomes genomes that were edited
to be HIV resistant so with potentially
boundless possibilities the question now
is what altered genes would a US soldier
need probably put some brains in them so
they can question the policies there are
already good soldiers I think I think
how God's created them is enough good
enough for me are you kidding me well
I'm asking you that the most outrageous
thing I've ever heard the benefits of
DNA could be to be used to live longer
happier maybe be less relying on things
like I don't know waste why why do we
use this with soldiers you don't like
the idea no I don't that's sad because
there's got to be consequences to that
oh I change no their strength their
vision that's you know anything anything
that would make them a better soldier I
suppose but before you let your
imagination run too wild remember the US
military says there is no need to worry
it's all for a good cause all these
technologies they are dual use you can
use them for good and you can use them
for evil Defense Advanced Research
Projects Agency is about using them for
good to protect our war fighters the
potential of genetic engineering should
not be underestimated there's a lot that
could be done beyond simply
fire-breathing always on fully
weaponized warriors and keep your eyes
out for the genetically modified
soldiers of the future unlike GMO foods
they may not always be labeled Caleb
Maupin RT New York
you